dans cette pub les boues issues de vos
fausses sceptiques
autrement dit ce qu'il reste des
matières fécales si vous disposez d'un
système d'assainissement non collectif
elles sont amenées ici dans cette usine
de traitement spécialisés par des
transporteurs agréés
seulement voilà le compte n'y est pas
vraiment en martinique on estime à 123
mille le nombre de tonnes de boues qui
devraient être collectés chaque année
pourtant les entreprises agréées n'en
connect que 26000 une première perte de
97 milles tonnes qui s'explique par un
défaut d'entretien de la part des
propriétaires
toutes ces boues produites qui ne sont
pas extraite elles sont donc de manière
diffuse çà et là finissent dans le
milieu naturel puisque lorsqu'une fausse
déborde tout cela va dans le dans le
milieu naturel
mais la pollution ne s'arrête pas là car
sur les vingt-six mille tonnes
collectées par les vidangeurs celui
mille arrive effectivement dans les deux
stations spécialisées en martinique les
18000 tellement quand seraient déversés
directement dans la nature par des
vidangeurs peu scrupuleux ou dans
certains cas réinjectée dans le circuit
des eaux usées comme nous le confiait
dans l'émission place publique de mars
dernier un ancien employé de société de
vidange
qu'est ce qui vous était demandée dans
cette entreprise de mettre les boules
deux fois sceptique dans une plaque
d'égout qui se trouve à l'intérieur d'un
dépôt
je leur ai dit que c'est pas
réglementaire pour les pollueurs
présumés l'intérêt serait d'engranger
les sommes normalement alloués au
traitement prenant l'exemple d'une
facture de vidange de 500 euros 250 sont
pour la vidange elle-même et 250 pour le
traitement le vidangeur vous facture la
totalité de la somme car c'est lui même
qui doit régler les usines spécialisées
lors du dépôt des boues en réalité ils
déversent les boues dans la nature et
garde l'intégralité des sommes pour lui
fin octobre
quatorze maires de martinique sont
montés au créneau dans une lettre
ouverte adressée aux préfets des
municipalités qui pour certaines
souhaitent se substituer aux
particuliers dans les opérations de
suivi du traitement des boues de vidange
avant la venue d'entreprises ou venez
voir la mairie pour expliquer ça aux
services de l'environnement le service
d'un jeune homme va vous accompagner de
vous avez une entreprise l'entreprise
quand il a vidangé doit vous donner un
document
où ils s'engagent à aller déverser dans
les lieux réservés spécialement pour apa
après service vous avez un document que
vous ramenez pour le service
environnement de l'environnement de la
commune en question mais aussi de la
police et là on pourra mieux contrôler
et limiter ces dégâts que subissent
notre environnement qu'on peut pas
continuer à se battre contre les
radicaux contre les pesticides et
aujourd'hui il y a ceux aux problèmes
qui se posent qui est volume des bleus
bout aujourd'hui chaque particulier peut
déjà exigé de l'entreprise de vidange un
bordereau de suivi mais peu de clients
le fonds l'activité d'assainissement est
soumise à désagréments temps pour les
vidangeurs que pour les usines de
traitement des professionnels dans
l'obligation de tenir des registres
précis exigible en cas de contrôle mais
l'état dispose t-il des moyens
suffisants pour opérer ces vérifications
en attendant chaque année plusieurs
milliers de tonnes de boues fécales
continue d'être déversés dans la nature
accentuant un peu plus les atteintes à
l'environnement